Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder:
Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Parlement hebdo".
Retour en 26 minutes
sur les événements
qui ont marqué
l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat cette semaine.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Nous accueillons
cette semaine
Hervé Marseille,
sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine
et vice-président
du groupe amitié France-Israël.
- Kathia Gilder:
Emmanuel Macron s'est exprimé
ce jeudi dans une allocution
solennelle.
Il a promis de tout faire
pour sauver
les otages français.
Et nous reverrons
les hommages
et les réactions
politiques à l'Assemblée
et au Sénat après les attentats
terroristes
du Hamas sur Israël.
On parlera également
du budget 2024,
que les députés
ont commencé à examiner.
Sous pression,
l'exécutif se prépare
à utiliser l'article 49-3.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Emmanuel Macron
a donc pris la parole hier soir.
Il a tenté de rassurer
sur le sort
de nos compatriotes
détenus par le Hamas.
- Emmanuel Macron:
Nos compatriotes
sont sans doute,
pour certains d'entre eux,
retenus en otage.
Je pense ce soir aux familles.
Je veux leur dire
que la France met
tout en oeuvre,
aux côtés des autorités
israéliennes,
pour les faire revenir sains
et saufs dans leurs foyers.
Jamais la France
n'abandonne ses enfants.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une première réaction
sur ce qu'a dit le président
de la République?
Que peut faire la France
pour nos otages français détenus
par le Hamas?
- Hervé Marseille:
J'étais à l'Elysée hier,
avec les responsables
des partis politiques.
A l'évidence,
une des priorités annoncées
par le chef de l'Etat,
c'est d'obtenir
la libération de nos otages.
Il y a une vingtaine
de Français
dont on ne sait pas
ce qu'ils sont devenus.
Certains
sont peut-être morts,
mais d'autres peuvent
être encore détenus
comme otages.
C'est la priorité de la France.
Après, on ne négocie
jamais en direct.
Tout cela relève du domaine
de la discrétion
et du secret.
On peut imaginer
qu'il y a des pays
de la région
qui sont des intermédiaires
pour essayer d'obtenir
la libération
de nos otages.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le président
de la République
a appelé longuement
à l'unité du pays.
On voit en France une hausse
des attaques antisémites.
Craignez-vous
que le conflit ne s'importe
en France?
- Hervé Marseille:
On doit le redouter.
Tout doit être fait
pour éviter
cette fracture
supplémentaire au sein
de notre pays.
C'est vrai
qu'il y a une montée
de la haine.
Il suffit de regarder
les réseaux sociaux.
Il y a une montée
des invectives
et des horreurs sont proférées.
Le chef
de l'Etat a dit
qu'il y avait eu environ 140
faits judiciarisés.
On voit bien
qu'il y a une montée
de la tension.
Il faut tout faire
pour éviter
que le conflit
ne s'importe chez nous.
On a vu qu'il y avait eu
des manifestations.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il faut les interdire?
- Hervé Marseille: Oui.
Parce qu'il y a des slogans
qui traitent Israël d'assassin.
On ne peut pas justifier
les actes
de violence.
La justice doit intervenir.
- Kathia Gilder:
Toute la semaine,
les hommages
et les réactions politiques
se sont succédés
après cette attaque
sans précédent du Hamas.
La droite demande
la qualification
de "crimes contre l'humanité".
La réaction ambiguë
de La France Insoumise suscite
les critiques.
- L'horreur.
La sidération.
- Des mots forts,
et l'émotion
dans la voix de Yaël Braun-Pivet.
Les députés ont rendu
hommage aux victimes
du massacre en Israël.
Le recueil de l'Assemblée
mardi a laissé place
à celui du Sénat mercredi.
- Gérard Larcher:
Je vous invite
à vous lever
pour observer une minute
de silence.
- Un moment solennel
sous les yeux
de l'ambassadeur
d'Israël en France.
Puis d'autres mots
forts ont résonné,
ceux de Gérard Larcher.
- Gérard Larcher:
Les massacres commis
dans les kibboutz
de Kfar Aza et Be'eri
ont un nom:
ce sont des crimes
contre l'humanité.
- Les sénateurs LR
souhaitent déposer
une résolution
pour qualifier les faits.
- Crimes
contre l'humanité,
ce sont les faits.
C'est bien le minimum.
- Mais Roger
Karoutchi demande
plus au gouvernement.
Il appelle aussi
à condamner
ceux qui ne soutiennent pas
Israël.
En ligne de mire,
La France Insoumise.
Mathilde Panot
a refusé de qualifier
le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste.
-
Mathilde Panot:
Ils ne changeront pas
notre position,
qui est celle de la paix.
- Dans l'hémicycle,
elle est conspuée
par les LR
et certains députés
de la majorité.
- Absolument rien
ne justifie le terrorisme.
- Marine Le Pen:
Ceux qui soutiennent
l'insoutenable,
l'excusent ou le relativisent,
et dont certains
siègent sur ces bancs,
ils sont dans l'atteinte
aux valeurs humaines.
- Ne pas clairement
reconnaître le Hamas
comme organisation
terroriste,
cela relève de l'indignité.
- Un comportement
également dénoncé
par le gouvernement.
Elisabeth Borne dit refuser
toute ambiguïté.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Face au drame terrible
qui frappe Israël,
notre devoir
est de veiller à l'unité
et à la cohésion nationales.
- La Première ministre
a également évoqué
les familles de victimes.
- Kathia Gilder:
La droite demande donc
au Sénat la qualification
de crimes
contre l'humanité.
C'est un terme
créé en 1945
dans les statuts
du tribunal de Nuremberg.
Est-ce qu'il faut
qualifier ces faits
de crimes contre l'humanité?
- Hervé Marseille: Oui.
A l'évidence, il faut le faire.
Je l'ai évoqué ce jeudi
devant le président.
A l'évidence,
c'est un sujet
dont il va falloir s'emparer.
Il y a le temps
du deuil,
il y a le temps
de la guerre et viendra
le moment où il faudra
traiter ce dossier.
- Kathia Gilder:
La procédure est longue.
- Hervé Marseille:
Il faut
que nous portions
devant le tribunal international
cette définition de crimes
contre l'humanité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pourquoi le chef
de l'Etat ne le fait pas?
- Hervé Marseille:
Il y a plus urgent
à faire.
Il faut étayer le dossier.
Il y a des médecins légistes
qui travaillent.
Ca viendra en son temps.
Je crois que c'est indispensable.
Ca permettra aussi de définir
les responsabilités.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bruno Retailleau
va déposer une résolution
sur ce sujet, notamment
pour évoquer
la qualification de "crimes
contre l'humanité".
J'imagine que les sénateurs
centristes
vont soutenir cet résolution.
- Hervé Marseille:
Oui, nous allons présenter
cette résolution ensemble.
J'imagine qu'elle sera signée
par d'autres groupes,
j'espère par le plus grand nombre.
Il faut être clairs.
Ca a été dit par tous
les orateurs.
Nous avons affaire
à des crimes de guerre,
à des scènes absolument horribles.
Il n'y a pas de "oui mais".
Le Hamas est un groupe terroriste.
Ce n'est pas
de la résistance
que de tirer
sur une rave party,
les résistants
ne décapitent pas
des bébés.
Ce sont des fanatiques
qui sont entrés
sur le territoire israélien,
à la grande surprise
du monde qui pensait
qu'Israël
était mieux armé pour sa défense.
Ils sont venus pour mourir.
- Kathia Gilder:
Est-ce que vous condamnez
néanmoins aussi
la stratégie de riposte
de l'armée israélienne,
qui fait
de nombreuses victimes?
- Hervé Marseille:
Chacun reconnaît
le droit à Israël de se défendre.
On ne peut pas imaginer
qu'Israël ait rencontré
la mort, comme ça a été le cas,
et qu'Israël fasse
un cessez-le-feu.
Il faut qu'Israël
puisse défendre
son peuple.
On sait qu'il y aura
des ripostes
très fortes.
Elles ont déjà commencé.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Mais il y a des victimes
civiles à Gaza.
Malgré le droit
à se défendre d'Israël,
est-ce qu'Israël
ne sort pas du droit
international?
- Hervé Marseille:
On sait bien
que le Hamas se sert
des habitants
de Gaza comme d'un bouclier
humain.
Ils servent d'otages,
malheureusement.
C'est l'un
des endroits du monde
les plus densément peuplés.
Il y a plus de 2 millions
d'habitants entassés
dans des conditions épouvantables.
Ils sont pris
en otage par le Hamas
depuis déjà fort longtemps.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle
il ne faut pas supprimer
l'aide humanitaire
qui existe en direction
de ces populations.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'Union Européenne fournit l'aide
la plus importante
à l'Autorité palestinienne.
Certains disent
qu'il faudrait couper
ces aides car elles seraient
détournées
par le Hamas.
- Hervé Marseille:
On sait
qu'il y a une partie
de l'aide
qui est détournée par le Hamas.
Mais il y a une partie
des couloirs humanitaires
qui apportent de l'eau,
de la nourriture
et des médicaments.
Et puis, il y a l'aide
au développement.
C'est cette aide
qu'il faut mesurer.
Il faut peut-être
la surprendre en partie
ou mieux la contrôler.
Il faut
que les associations
et les ONG soient beaucoup
mieux contrôlées.
On ne peut pas en rajouter
vis-à-vis
de la population de Gaza.
On ne peut pas la tuer.
Il faut qu'elle puisse survivre.
L'aide humanitaire
est indispensable.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Au Parlement,
il y a eu une quasi
unanimité de soutien
à Israël de la part de tous
les groupes politiques,
même si La France Insoumise a fait
preuve d'une certaine ambiguïté.
Mathilde Panot
ne parle pas d'attaque terroriste
mais de crimes de guerre.
- Hervé Marseille:
En effet,
je suis surpris et je pense
que LFI s'est disqualifiée.
Ne pas reconnaître
les horreurs du Hamas,
les qualifier de résistants...
- Kathia Gilder:
Comment expliquer
ce refus de La France
Insoumise de qualifier
le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste?
- Hervé Marseille:
Je pense
que c'est un calcul
électoral de bas étage.
Je ne veux pas en dire
plus car ce serait
leur faire trop d'honneur.
La France Insoumise
est lâchée
de toutes parts.
La politique a des règles.
Il y a des règles
humanitaires élémentaires.
Quand on voit
ce qui s'est passé,
on ne peut que reconnaître
le caractère terroriste
et abominable
de ce que fait le Hamas.
Ne pas le reconnaître,
c'est aller
contre l'évidence.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Que faire
contre cette position
de La France Insoumise?
Certains proposent
la dissolution
de ce parti.
Quelle est votre position?
- Hervé Marseille:
Il y a des règles
dans un Etat de droit.
La première, en démocratie,
c'est l'élection.
J'espère que les Français
qui ont pu porter
leur voix sur LFI
tiendront compte
du comportement de ces élus.
Dans les sondages,
on voit que 84%
des Français condamnent
cette position.
Ensuite, il y a le droit.
S'il y a des plaintes,
c'est à la justice d'agir.
- Kathia Gilder:
Elisabeth Borne
est allée jusqu'à déplorer
une forme d'antisémitisme.
- Hervé Marseille:
Mais ce n'est pas nouveau.
Souvenez-vous de madame Obono
qui recevait monsieur Corbyn.
Des propos qui ont été tenus
à différentes reprises
par les membres de LFI.
Ils sont toujours
sur le fil du rasoir
parce qu'ils appuient
sur un électorat
qu'ils essaient
de flatter au maximum.
C'est répugnant.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Ce conflit pose
des questions géopolitiques.
Que faire face aux pays
alliés du Hamas?
- La guerre
est revenue
et nous ne voulons pas la voir.
Je ne parle pas seulement
de la guerre
du Hamas contre Israël,
mais aussi
des conflits en mer
de Chine, en Orient
et maintenant en Europe.
C'est la guerre
des dictatures
contre la démocratie.
Elle est mondiale.
Les mains
qui ont tranché la gorge
des enfants d'Israël
venaient de Gaza,
mais leur cerveau est à Téhéran.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Les occidentaux doivent-ils
prendre des sanctions
contre les dirigeants iraniens?
- Hervé Marseille:
J'ai dénoncé
cette situation au Sénat,
en mettant également
en cause le Qatar.
Après, il faut mesurer
les implications,
il ne suffit pas de dénoncer.
Les Américains
ont commencé à le faire,
avec un certain
nombre de preuves,
mais je pense
qu'il y a une défaillance
au niveau de l'Europe.
Nous appartenons
à une communauté
qui devrait parler
d'une seule voix,
comme nous l'avons
fait concernant
le dossier ukrainien.
Là, il y a eu
beaucoup de confusion
dans les réactions
de la communauté européenne.
On suspend des aides,
et finalement
on ne les suspend pas...
Il faut arrêter la confusion
et parler d'une seule voix
pour dénoncer ce qui doit l'être.
Et il faut également
relancer le processus
de paix.
Après la guerre, vient la paix.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous croyez vraiment
qu'il y a une relance
possible du processus
de paix?
Vous pensez que la paix
est possible
à moyen terme?
- Hervé Marseille:
On ne peut pas abandonner
la paix.
Il y a eu le processus
des accords d'Abraham.
- Alexandre Poussart:
C'est le rapprochement
entre Israël et certains
pays arabes.
- Hervé Marseille:
Le Hamas cherche justement
à mettre un terme
à ces rapprochements.
Mais les accords tiennent.
On le voit avec la réaction
de l'Arabie saoudite
et du Maroc.
Il est important
d'accompagner les dynamiques
des accords d'Abraham.
- Kathia Gilder:
Avec quels interlocuteurs?
- Hervé Marseille:
Avec les pays
de la région,
avec les pays arabes
qui sont signataires
des accords d'Abraham.
Il faut relancer
le processus de paix,
parce que sinon,
on aura des événements similaires
tous les ans.
On ne peut pas faire l'impasse.
On avait cru qu'avec
les accords d'Abraham,
on écartait le problème
palestinien,
mais il revient avec force.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Benyamin Netanyahou a-t-il aussi
une responsabilité
dans l'échec
de la paix, notamment
avec la poursuite
de la colonisation?
- Hervé Marseille:
Collectivement,
que ce soit les Américains,
le gouvernement israélien,
nous-mêmes,
nous avons été trop absents
du dossier palestinien
en pensant
qu'il ne se passait plus rien.
Aujourd'hui,
ce dossier revient
devant nous avec
l'horreur
que nous observons.
Il faut régler
la situation actuelle.
Israël va, j'imagine,
monter en puissance
sur le plan militaire.
Mais parallèlement,
il faut que la diplomatie agisse
pour relancer
le processus de paix
et accompagner la dynamique
des accords d'Abraham.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci pour cet éclairage
sur la situation au Proche-Orient.
Les députés ont entamé
l'examen du budget 2024.
Ca s'annonce difficile
pour le gouvernement,
qui n'a qu'une
majorité relative
au Parlement.
On va parler
des points chauds
de ce budget.
- Sur le papier,
le gouvernement
avait deux objectifs:
sortir progressivement
du "quoi qu'il en coûte"
et mettre
des mécanismes
de protection face
à l'inflation sans ajouter
de la dette supplémentaire.
- L'argent gratuit, c'est fini.
C'est fini pour longtemps.
Il serait donc
totalement irresponsable
de poursuivre les dépenses
au même rythme,
au moment où les taux
d'intérêt
ont atteint les 4%
et alourdissent
la charge de la dette.
- Mais dès la commission,
difficile
pour la majorité
relative de tenir
ses ambitions.
Le gouvernement
enchaîne les revers.
Le président de la commission
des finances
a fait adopter
un amendement pour taxer
les super dividendes.
- Je vous incite à réfléchir
aux messages envoyés.
Si vous demandez
des efforts aux gens,
il faut en demander
à tout le monde.
- Un amendement
voté grâce aux voix
de la gauche, mais aussi du MoDem.
Le gouvernement
est aussi défié
par sa propre majorité.
Le MoDem se montre
très attaché
à des mesures
de justice fiscale,
quand Horizons veut
baisser les impôts.
Les débats dans l'hémicycle
commencent mardi après-midi
et finiront inévitablement
par un 49-3.
Reste à savoir quand.
- Kathia Gilder:
"L'argent gratuit,
c'est fini", nous dit
Bruno Le Maire.
Il prévoit des économies
avec ce budget.
C'est assez?
- Hervé Marseille: Pas vraiment.
Peut mieux faire.
Il y a des dispositifs
exceptionnels,
avec le bouclier tarifaire.
Ce n'est pas nouveau.
Nous avons un déficit annuel.
François Fillon
disait déjà
qu'il était à la tête
d'un Etat en faillite.
Il est donc temps
de faire des économies.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Mais quelles économies?
Quelles sont les dépenses
qu'on peut réduire?
- Hervé Marseille:
Il faut raboter
tout un tas de dépenses.
Il y a un tas
d'agences qui existent
et dont on se demande
à quoi elles servent.
- Kathia Gilder: Et ça suffira?
- Hervé Marseille: On peut faire
plein d'économies partout.
Il suffit de s'y mettre.
Il faut une volonté
politique, déjà.
Il faut à la fois
des économies,
mais aussi trouver des recettes.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On a vu les députés
de la commission
des finances adopter
une taxe sur les super dividendes.
Vous aviez,
les centristes,
demandé une taxe
sur les superprofits.
Vous êtes confiants
à la faire adopter
dans le budget?
- Hervé Marseille: Oui et non.
Je vais m'expliquer.
Nous avons déjà supprimé
beaucoup d'impôts:
la taxe d'habitation,
la redevance
de la télévision...
On a compensé par quoi?
Je ne suis pas persuadé
que les gens
s'en soient aperçu.
Il y a un problème social.
Il y a 9 millions
de gens dans le pays
qui sont en situation
de précarité.
Certains ont du mal
à se nourrir
tous les jours.
Est-ce qu'on peut
continuer
à avoir des dividendes
insolents
de la part d'un certain nombre
de grandes entreprises,
qui distribuent
des dividendes faramineux?
Je pense que l'angle social
est un angle mort
de la politique
gouvernementale
depuis plusieurs années.
Il y a eu quelques pas positifs
en direction
de l'emploi...
- Kathia Gilder:
Mais le gouvernement
ne veut
toujours pas entendre
parler d'une taxe
sur les super dividendes.
- Hervé Marseille:
L'adoption d'une telle taxe
est une bonne chose.
Mais s'il y a un 49-3,
le gouvernement
va sortir cette taxe du texte.
Vraisemblablement,
c'est ce qui va se passer
et je trouve que c'est dommage.
Il y a un problème
d'exemplarité sociale.
C'était un moyen
de montrer aux gens
qu'on prenait aussi
aux plus riches.
- Kathia Gilder:
En parlant de taxe,
les députés
ont voté l'exit tax
pour sanctionner
les actionnaires
qui transfèrent
leur fonds hors de France
pour échapper aux impôts.
- Hervé Marseille:
Je soutiens
cette mesure.
Elle est modulable
d'année en année,
selon la situation.
Il y a tout un tas
de leviers fiscaux
qui permettent
de retrouver des recettes.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pour terminer
sur le budget.
Le 49-3, finalement,
à quoi ça sert
de débattre et de faire
des amendements
sur ce budget?
- Hervé Marseille:
Ce sont nos institutions.
Le Parlement est fait
pour débattre.
Nous débattons, nous votons.
Le gouvernement utilise les armes
qui sont à sa disposition.
- Kathia Gilder: Merci,
ce sera le mot de la fin.
Hervé Marseille, merci
d'avoir été notre invité.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA